es war ein gigantischer vulkanausbruch
fast zwei kubikkilometer material wollen
wir ausgeworfen anderthalb mal so viel
wie bei der explosion des morgens ansatz
hat 80 es entstand kein normaler kater
sondern eine caldera mit einem
durchmesser von viereinhalb kilometern
doch niemand hat es mitbekommen 2012
also vor kurzem erst nur auf dem meer da
trieb eine riesige insel aus bimsstein
mit 400 quadratkilometern da sind 100
mehr als beim alter es geht um den
größten vulkanausbruch unter wasser in
den letzten 100 jahren
jetzt hat eine expedition eine
unwirtliche landschaft in einem kilo
meter wassertiefe entdeckt und die
unglaublichen ausmaße dieser unterwasser
katastrophe jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen die
eruption des vulkans im jahr 2012 ein
fast unvorstellbares ereignis denn
hierbei handelt sich wortwörtlich um
einen unterwasser giganten der damals
aus insgesamt 14 knoten lavaströme
herauskatapultiert und nicht nur dass
einige lavaströme haben wohl auch
größere erdrutsche zur folge gehabt doch
wie heftig und komplex die eruption im
jahr 2012 tatsächlich war hat jetzt ein
forschungsteam aus australien konkret
ermitteln können erst jetzt hinweise
darauf dass sich detaillierte
untersuchungen deshalb von vulkans
nordöstlich von neuseeland lohnen
könnten gab dem forschungsteam
tatsächlich eine an ein zufallsfund im
sommer 2012 hat nämlich flug passagiere
über dem südwestpazifik eine äußerst
interessante entdeckung gemacht ein
gigantisches floss aus bimsstein
unfassbare 400 quadratkilometer groß
also knapp 100 quadratkilometer größer
als malta der kleinste mitgliedsstaat
der europäischen union bei den stein
handelte sich um ein gestein das bei
vulkanausbrüchen entsteht enthält so
viele gasblasen dass es meistens stimmt
wenn es sich nicht vollsaugt und da
diese entdeckung mitten auf dem ozean
weit entfernt vom nächsten land gemacht
worden war stand auch gleich fest dass
dieser bimsstein vom meeresgrund stammen
muss entstanden durch den ausbruch eines
unterwasservulkans durch die analyse
seiner trifft richtung ergab sich dann
der schluss ziemlich schnell
das bimsstein floss bei dem ausbruch des
harfe untersee vulkans entstanden sein
muss
er ist umgeben von einer kette aus
vulkan
da sich in diesem gebiet die pazifische
unter die australische platte schiebt
und die expedition des australischen
forschungsteams war tatsächlich äußerst
aufschlussreich durch einen
ferngesteuerten autonomen tauchroboter
kamen sie ihren einige proben des
vulkanischen materials und die
auswertung der daten ja die war mehr als
überraschend zitat als wir uns die
aufzeichnung des tauchroboters an
schauten sahen wir all diese buckel auf
den meeresgrund ich dachte das so nah
des roboters ist gestört so einer der
beteiligten forscher dem zu
doch die buckel so wie er es nannte
stellten sich dann als gigantische bin
steinbrocken heraus teilweise so groß
wie lastwagen dazu soll
zitat etwas vergleichbares habe ich noch
nie auf dem meeresgrund gesehen als das
forschungsteam versuchte die brocken zu
bergen zerbröselten diese das wiederum
liegt die vermutung nahe dass die bams
steine sehr langsam auf dem meeresgrund
gesunken sein müssen denn sonst wären
sie ja bereits beim prozess in sich
zerfallen und der tauchroboter liegt
hatte eine zweite unglaubliche
erkenntnis insgesamt 14 schlote müssen
bei der eruption im jahr 2012 beteiligt
gewesen sein
noch heute sind die erkaltete lavaströme
als riesige la wartung zu sehen bis zu
500 meter breit und 30 meter hoch doch
welche konsequenzen hätte ein
vulkanausbruch ähnlichen ausmaßes
anderen vielleicht erinnert sich der
eine oder andere noch an den ausbruch
des isländischen vulkans
eyjafjallajökull
das war 2010 und die vulkanasche sorgt
dafür dass in weiten teilen nord und
mitteleuropas der flugverkehr lahmgelegt
war für mehrere tage das hatte
erhebliche nachteile für die wirtschaft
und das große problem bleibt es ist fast
unmöglich vulkane sicher einschätzen zu
können oder in den griff zu bekommen
oder vorherzusagen wann da was passiert
und das ist aber unabdingbar um die
menschheit im worst case zu retten
nämlich beim ausbruch eines vulkans ja
wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema und
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wir
dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an
dann erfahrt ihr nämlich vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
ihr könnt dort die
rechts in der redaktion von klicks und
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken katastrophe
durch supervulkan hat nasa die lösung
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran